c'est aimer les quatre heures les plus
abstraites
[Musique]
j'ai entendu à ma droite une détonation
et à ce moment là c'était quand quand le
terroriste il a tué monsieur brown qui
attendait justement ma caisse et après
j'entends je me rappelle très bien le
bruit des pas lourds que théorie ce qui
vient en fait qui se met devant en face
de moi donc moi je suis je suis à cassis
parterre lui les deux bouts en face de
moi avec sont ces armes
on avait deux kalachnikovs une dans
chaque main et il m'a dit cette phrase
que je pourrai jamais oublier immédiate
est pas encore morte je ne veux pas
mourir et il a tiré
c'est en regardant à côté de moi et en
voyant l'impact de la balle dans ma
caisse que j'ai compris que que
clairement j'ai j'avais failli mourir
quand tu nous as tous assis ensemble on
n'était pas très loin de yoann de douane
et samuel me disais c'est un très bon
ami us design regarde johan verbist et
qu'est ce qu'on fait et je m'en veux
énormément les seuils de pâques de pas
tout concentrer sur lui ne pense pas
yoel il faut qu'on s'assure et c'est
exactement ce que moi j'ai fait en fait
pendant tout la prise d'otage essayer de
ne pas faire cas de ses gémissements des
corps autour de nous des corps que moi
je devais en jambes et à chaque fois
qu'il m'a demandé quelque chose pour
pouvoir circuler dans le magasin des
autres brodeur l'odeur cette odeur de
poudre de faire du sang qui a coagulé
c'est aimer les quatre heures les plus
horribles abstraite
evel
[Musique]